[Music]
in this movie this movie depicts frat
life fraternity life zac efron dave
franco you're the Dean i'm just curious
did you have any experience with
fraternities at all when you were in
college
no no not college no cuz I chose a
college that didn't have fraternities or
sororities okay so they didn't have went
to Vassar so there was no fraternities
no sorority right that's right okay
we had cocktail parties you know we
didn't but if we went to a party and
there was a keg I left really yeah you
were a little bit of a I don't want to
say you were a little you're a little
bit of a prude maybe in college all
right but you think now you'd see that
you'd see a keg and you'd be like I want
no part of this that's right it's like
okay everyone's just gonna get really
crazy and stupid and I'm not I don't
want any part of it nice sloppy drunk
uh-huh
right cuz that's very different from
martinis yeah yeah well you don't get
drunk from vodka and vermouth you get
drunk in that cool madman way no but I
had already gone to fraternity parties
in high school oh I went yeah cuz I was
looking for you know fraternity men well
now why were you looking for I mean I I
know that sometimes girls in high school
they were women in high school they want
to like yeah right exactly yeah cuz you
know the guys in high school were too
young for us and so we wanted to meet
you know more mature men and I don't
know why I kept expecting that to be
sort of like in Blazers and ties and put
pipes you know like what I had seen in a
movie at some point from the 40s right
you know like it's a dinner club and I
was really disappointed you're not
describing a frat experience oh I know
there's usually like a pig running
around and people getting jumping out
windows and yeah worse I mean just like
much worse than I could have ever
expected I went and went oh no well we
have to leave and I came with other
people what am I gonna have trapped I
think something Bad's gonna happen there
just so you said all that out loud
oh my god this is terrible something bad
is going to happen yes I did very good
I really did all right I'd to tell my
friends like we have to go
can't we go don't you want to go look
I'm having fun I'm going fat guys room
don't do you don't want to do that no
your virtue you know your virtue what
happens your virtue might be spoil your
Maidenhead could you have those glasses
that are at the end of a long stick you
mustn't do that
I have to ask you about a crazy rumor
there's this there are always these
friends reunion rumors and we've all
learned that okay that's probably crazy
that's probably the latest one that I've
read a bunch of places that there's
gonna be a friend's musical oh really
yes that's the latest one that's out
there note no truth to the friends
musical I don't know I'm not I wouldn't
be consulted I don't you weren't even
aware what movie you were yeah you went
to a frat party to meet sophisticated
types so so so there would be no I mean
could it work as a musical do you think
friends sure well actually it like this
could be a musical this is a musical
this is we're gonna I'm singing this at
the end of the show I'm just curious
like your character Phoebe sang a lot on
yeah and so that's the one part where
you could see like oh I could see the
big smelly cat number is fantastic you
gotta see it yeah yeah six hundred
dancers and cats come out you don't
really like to sing do you I mean it you
don't you don't enjoy it no okay
only at home yeah where no one can hear
quietly that's so funny that you were
the one character on the show that sang
but you really don't like it no I don't
I don't really like it at all do you
like karaoke no I don't ok well how many
times have we done karaoke you like
karaoke right I'm one of those people
that likes to sing like Elvis songs
karaoke I like that kind of thing yeah
look I did I went once and I thought
okay this looks like it's a lot of fun
and I'm gonna do something funny I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do hava nagila
and it was funny for five seconds right
that's to me the problem with karaoke
cuz the first few seconds like oh look
at that right that's the problem a lot
of things from there doing a show every
night was he going with this